it's now more than 50 days since russia
launched its invasion of ukraine in his
nightly video address president vladimir
zelinsky praised the ukrainian people
for surviving so long under relentless
attack
ukraine is also claiming a victory in
its efforts to repel russian forces at
sea
russia's military has confirmed that its
main warship in the black sea the moskva
sank while being towed back to port in
stormy weather moscow says the ship
suffered a fire and explosion but
ukraine says the damage was caused by
its missiles hitting the vessel on
wednesday off the port of odessa
as it turned out this new ukrainian
postage stamp was prophetic shown off
just hours before the incident by
president vladimir zelinsky with the
message the russian warship always has
only one direction
russia blames a fire for the loss
ukraine though has a slightly different
take
in the black sea region the moskva
warship was hit by neptune anti-ship
missiles it sustained substantial damage
a fire started other ships tried to
provide assistance but a storm and the
powerful explosion of ammunition turned
the ship over and it started sinking
the mask came to prominence at the start
of the war
being told to go f itself when it tried
to capture ukraine's snake island in the
black sea
[Music]
month the man behind those words was
awarded a medal for his bravery
initially feared killed he and other
soldiers were taken captive before being
freed in a prisoner exchange the muskra
was the main ship in russia's black sea
fleet
its loss marks a significant reduction
in russia's firepower in the area and a
huge symbolic blow for moscow
the loss of the warship is a setback for
russia and a symbolic victory for
ukraine which zelinski picked up on in
his address
i've seen people who aren't politicians
do more in these 50 days than some
statesmen who claim to be leaders
these people have shown that russian
aviation can be beaten even though
russia has spent tens of billions of
dollars on systems to protect its
aircraft
and these people have shown that russian
ships can only go
to the bottom
and for more on this i'm joined now by
air marshal phil osborne a former chief
of defense intelligence for the united
kingdom and now a director with
universal defense and security solutions
a global defense consultancy air marshal
losing the moskva how much does that
hurt
um well it's pretty titamic as far as
both ukraine and russia are concerned
and whether or not um it's through
russian negligence uh or a ukrainian
attack i think it's a fairly major
impact it's a second major vessel that
russia have lost in the in the black sea
it will have an air defense and a
anti-ship capability um but if it is the
subject of a ukrainian attack then it's
going to force russia to change its
tactics it's going to have to stand back
a lot more it's going to have to think
about how it uses
their naval assets to support the land
campaign so so it's it's a really major
impact either way
this morning there were explosions
around the capital could that be a
symbolic lashing out because of the
sinking do you think
um
i'm not surprised i mean ukraine is a
war zone um and and although russia has
said it's refocused it's attached to the
east that doesn't in any way mean it's
going to self-censor it um any attacks
elsewhere it could actually be
retaliation for reported ukrainian
attacks on russian towns near the border
with ukraine um but i think we can
expect to see
russian attacks across ukraine
especially against those important
supply lines uh from a from a ukrainian
point of view
and just to return to intelligence which
is your specialty how much is real time
intelligence provided by the u.s and
nato countries important to the war
effort and in a related question how
important is the intelligence coming
from citizens with smartphones who send
pictures of tanks for instance to the
army's telegram channels
well i think we're seeing one of the
first wars um where
everything is transparent social media
has transformed what what we know uh and
transform what commanders know about
their opposition um so so i think this
is a major change and and a much more
open intelligence picture is both good
and bad depending on where you sit in
terms of western support
western support is critical to ukraine
and it will become increasingly
important and intelligence will be will
be one element of that support what that
support will do is give ukraine a good
idea about
where russian forces are
and the kind of vulnerabilities they're
posing and the kind of opportunities
therefore that ukraine has
and you're
in mentioning support i i i would like
to ask you about the importance of
supply lines and logistics uh for both
sides uh and for for how important it is
for the west to keep supplies going if
ukraine is to win
um
the next few weeks frankly are are
critical to the outcome of the campaign
what campaign whether russia's um
dreadful illegal invasion of ukraine is
successful or whether it's repulsed um
the west has really got to step up it's
done it's done okay so far um but this
is net russia is redeploying its forces
across
russia to support this forthcoming
offensive in the east and the west has
really got to re-arm and then resupply
ukraine um over the next few weeks this
is this is a critical period
and the west has really got to show that
it means what it says
and
this psychology to all of this as we
were discussing about the sinking of the
mosque on the effect that that might
have a date on the calendar that is
important psychologically to the
russians as you know well is a day of
victory on may the 9th when they
celebrate victory in world war ii how
important is it for vladimir putin to
have a military success by then
um i imagine it's very important to him
but
the war doesn't follow desirable
timelines it never has it never will
and
and i can't see
him achieving even a limited success
sufficient for the kind of declaration
he wants in may the weather is pretty
bad in the east at the moment and that
will slow things up even more
and also
frankly the ukrainians are showing
incredibly robust resistance
really coming back at the russians and i
think that's going to continue so so i
suspect putin is in for a disappointing
mayday announcement there'll probably be
one um but it will be propaganda if
nothing else
eric marshall phil osborne thanks so
much for that insight